la sortie du confinement prend forme
outre atlantique
35 des 50 états américains s'apprêtent
où ont déjà commencé à lever certaines
mesures de restriction au texas
les commerces dont les restaurants
ouvrent à condition de se restreindre à
25% de l'activité habituelle est de
mettre en place une série de protections
contre le virus nous avons décidé
d'installer des paroi en plexiglas
autour du bar nous en avons aussi au
stand des hôtesses tous nos clients tous
nos employés vont porter des masques et
des gants et nous prenez vraiment toutes
les précautions possibles à new york
chicago ou encore ici à los angeles
les manifestations anti confinement se
poursuivre ouvrez la californie scandent
les contestataires drapeau américain et
pancartes à la main ils réclament la
levée des privations de liberté on doit
pouvoir sortir le virus est là pour un
bon moment comme la grippe alors voilà
on doit manifester
ce n'est pas pire que la grippe bien sûr
ce n'est pas la grippe mais ce n'est pas
pire ceux qui sont malades doivent
rester chez eux et se soigner mais il
faut que les gens en bonne santé
puissent travailler sortir et avoir une
vie sociale
le gouvernement essaie de gouverner nos
vies et il faut qu'on résiste
d'autres états sont en train de rouvrir
gavin newsom doit suivre la marche sinon
il va tout perdre il va perdre tous ceux
qui le soutiennent
parallèlement à cette contestation la
course aux traitements s'accélère
l'agencé américaine du médicament en
accord avec l'administration trump a
autorisé l'utilisation du médicament
expérimental rem daisy vire le locataire
de la maison blanche estime prometteur
ce traitement qui pourrait accélérer de
plusieurs jours la guérison des patients
gravement atteints par le virus
je suis heureux d'annoncer que gilead a
reçu une autorisation d'utilisation
d'urgence de l'agencé américaine du
médicament pour le rêve d y virent et
vous savez de quoi il s'agit car ça fait
la une dans les journaux et les médias
depuis quelques temps un médicament
important pour les patients hospitalisés
attendu coronavirus elle c'est vraiment
une situation très prometteuse
si la levée des mesures drastiques de
restriction s'accélère les bilans
quotidiens reste lourd dans le pays le
plus touché au monde
avec près de 2000 nouvelles victimes
chaque jour